Arrancan los juegos del hambre.
Del 1 al 10, ¿cuántas ganas tenéis de este draft?
Yo siempre los draft un 10.
Un 11.
Un 13.
¿Qué pasa, pizarritas?
Hoy tenemos un draft internacional
por el que Nahuel Miranda ya se ha creado
un par de veces en los minutos previos
porque es verdad que el reto es complicado, ¿vale?
El reto es formar al mejor equipo del fútbol europeo
en el siglo XXI,
y el mejor equipo de la historia.
Y el mejor equipo de la historia.
En el siglo XXI, con varios requisitos, varias limitaciones.
Un jugador por club
y un jugador por país.
En el país contamos dónde ha sido internacional
y en el club contamos dónde ha jugado más partidos.
Es decir, no podemos decir
Cristiano Ronaldo es Sporting de Portugal.
Ni Juve.
Tendríamos que decir Real Madrid.
Porque Leo Messi no valdría con el PSG
solo con el FC Barcelona.
En el caso de que algún jugador,
que me parece complicado,
Roy Neymar, imaginaos que
donde más ha jugado es en el Santos,
pues iríamos al segundo equipo.
Sería el primer europeo.
Creo que no hay ningún caso así,
pero lo estaba pensando por el tema de Neymar.
Y por si acaso...
Pues me acabas de joder el 11.
¿Sí?
Sí, hombre, joder.
¿Por qué?
Porque Neymar entraba dentro de mis planes.
Ahora, si contamos el primer europeo,
ya es el Barcelona.
Ya no me encaja en el Barcelona.
No, no, pero a ver, esto es un traf...
No sabía que un jugador es europeo.
Es europeo, son equipos europeos.
Bueno, ya me...
Pero Neymar no juega en el fútbol europeo.
Es verdad, Miguel.
Lo que pasa es que tiene más partidos en Brasil.
Esto no lo dijiste.
Te lo digo ya.
Hacemos un draft internacional,
siglo XXI, un jugador por equipo y país.
El equipo elegido es el que haya jugado más partidos.
Gracias, Alex.
Si Barça, no PSG.
Bueno, esto lo hablamos ayer en persona.
Bueno, no.
No, no, no.
No me engañéis a mi padre.
Bueno, es cierto.
Fútbol europeo es un deporte negocial
si el precio es justo.
Clubes europeos...
La silla caliente.
Es el momento
de sortear.
¡Boh!
¿Puedes hacer todo el draft
con estas gafas, por favor?
Por favor, Betty Boop.
Vamos a sortear
quién empieza, ¿vale?
Aunque creo que Nahuel se merecería empezar.
Pero bueno, vamos a hacer un sorteo.
Ya sabéis cómo va. Sacamos unos deditos
y empieza a contar desde
mí, Adri, Alex, Nahuel.
Y luego el draft es inverso.
Esto no cambia respecto a los que ya hemos hecho.
Una, dos
y tres.
Cinco, ocho, diez.
Uno, dos, tres, cuatro, cinco, seis, siete, ocho, nueve, diez.
Arranca Adri, luego Alex,
luego Nahuel
y finalmente cierro yo.
Siempre muchísima suerte tengo.
En fin. Adrián Blanco.
Venga.
Tenemos derecho. Por cierto, 4-4-2
o 4-2-3-1, dijimos.
Exactamente. 4-4-2 o 4-2-3-1.
Por favor, no me metáis a media
puntas en el centro del campo.
¿Vale, Alex?
¿Cacá interior
junto, yo que sé,
a Ruy Costa? No.
Pero bueno, no valdrían
por el equipo, ¿no? Pero una cosa.
Posición.
No, no, no.
No mares.
Vale, vale, luego ya veremos los problemas.
Adrián Blanco.
Venga. Leo Messi.
Vale.
Alex de Llano.
Cristiano Ronaldo,
Real Madrid, Portugal,
pero...
No, por eso.
Vale.
No, puedes decir que...
Es que es la primera trampa.
Es que si quieres hacer la primera trampa
con el PIC número dos y Cristiano Ronaldo
tronco...
Cristiano... Cristiano
Di Pettino, puedes decir.
Vale.
Nahuel Miranda.
Eh...
Es que la vida es una mierda,
tío.
La vida es dolorosa.
Es que, tío, se me está ocurriendo
una atroleada, tío.
Es que esto es horrible.
Pero la voy a hacer.
Va. Eh...
Vean, en el centro...
Harry Kane.
Tottenham. ¿Qué cabrón?
Muy buena. Es que muy buena.
Muy buena.
Sí, señor. Ya, pero es el primer PIC.
Me voy a arrepentir yo.
¿Qué?
El primer PIC. Me voy a arrepentir yo, creo.
Vale.
Yo ahora mismo...
Tengo dos.
Evidentemente.
Vale. Voy a coger
Neymar Jr.
Fútbol Club Barcelona.
Y luego...
Voy a coger...
Hmm...
A...
Killian Mbappé.
Paris Saint-Germain.
Neymar en la izquierda
y Mbappé en punta, entiendo.
Sí.
Vale.
Y me toca a mí, ¿no?
Te toca a ti.
¿Qué?
Eh...
Una consulta breve que hacer.
Eh... ¡Qué putada esto!
Hmm...
Me voy a quedar con...
Lucas Modric, Real Madrid.
Muy buena.
Yo es la duda que tenía con Mbappé.
Porque el tema de la nacionalidad...
Sí.
Me toca. Te toca.
Lucas Modric, Doble Pibote.
No me nomeé.
No, no. Si aquí el único que...
O sea, yo es verdad que la lío.
La líe con Matías Oliveira y creo que fue Mar Pubil
en el draft de Descendidos.
Pero aquí el
que quinyula es el señor...
Fernández Aparicio.
Pero vamos.
Vení, inicio Junior, ¿eh?
Ha habido bastantes pizarritas
que me han mandado...
O sea, que ellos hacen sus propios drafts
y me han pedido que los puntúe.
Luego hay cabreos.
Y alguno hace trampas feas, ¿eh?
Está feo, está feo hacer trampas.
No las hagáis.
Aunque contra Gimtana, sí.
Para mí...
Thierry Henry.
Arsenal, Francia...
Delantero.
Sí.
Thierry Henry es muy buena, ¿eh?
Adrián Blanco, eliges dos.
Vale.
Pues elijo...
Fran Ribery.
Qué bueno.
Y...
En el Bayern, obviamente.
Checal.
Y...
Ostras.
A ver, que no me quiero
limitar.
Giorgio Chiellini.
En defensa, con la Juve.
Ostras.
Alex.
Centro del Campo,
Español, Barça,
Xavi Hernández.
Y...
Ah, bueno, si yo coje a Neymar.
No, es que lo tenía...
Me he hecho un prototipo de 11 idílico.
Por decirlo de alguna manera.
Y...
Lo va a rescatando.
Claro, claro. De hecho, ya lo he jodido.
Porque tenía la alternativa Messi-Cristiano.
Y por lo que sea, no ha golao.
Miranda Parera.
Con Modri y Keyin, de momento.
Me he quedado con Virgil
Van Dijk.
Muy bueno.
De momento, me has hecho tres
muy buenos. Lo digo para cuando luego hagamos
las valoraciones. Ya, bueno, pero están bien
tirados desde un punto de vista estratégico.
Pero luego tienes que culminar.
Ya, ya. Solo difícil siempre.
Historia de mi vida, manolo. A mí me pasa
igual.
Vale. A ver.
¿Quién le toca?
Yo, a mí. Tengo que elegir
dos. Dame un segundito.
Vale.
A ver.
Voy a coger
a uno de mis jugadores.
Ah, no, claro. No puedo ya.
No.
Vale.
Vamos a tirar de Astucia,
¿vale?
Mohamed Salah.
Muy bueno.
Y
seguimos con
la táctica Astucia.
Radamel Falcao.
Mónaco.
Hostia, Radamel Falcao.
Es buenísimo
Radamel Falcao para esa combo.
Colombiano.
Y Mónaco es
como el de...
Hay uno que me gusta.
El de Harry Kane es un poco eso.
Inglés y Tottenham
pues es una buena combo.
Vale.
TocaNau.
Eh...
Quiero
quemar, no quiero quemar, no quiero quemar,
pero...
Joder, es que es complicado.
O sea, tengo opciones.
Pero no me gusta ninguna.
O sea, no me gusta ninguna.
Te entiendo.
¿Qué?
Necesito
hacer un chequeo rápido.
Vale, tranquilo.
Esto es complicado. Intento que no quede muy
denso, pero ya sabéis que
es complicado.
Qué putada esto.
Hay un jugador que por siete partidos no me cae
en el club que...
Duro.
Uah, qué buena esta.
Por favor, deja de aporrear el teclado,
Alex, cada vez que buscas a un jugador.
¿Soy yo? Perdón.
Creo que es mi teclado.
Joder, qué complicada es esta mierda.
Arraf Hakimi
para Issaan Germain.
¿Qué tal? Muy bueno.
Un poco porro, ¿eh?
Arraf Hakimi. Ostras.
¿Por qué?
Campeones de la Champions, tíos de la Champions.
El PSG... Bueno, me callo.
Quiero ver los vuestros.
Quiero decir, aparte ya habéis gastado PSG la mayoría.
¿Voy yo, no?
No, Alex.
Alex tiene a Xavi, a Cristiano
Ronaldo y a Titi Enri.
Vale.
Vale, pues voy a dejar
este ya cerrado.
Pavel Netvech Juventus. Muy buena.
Muy buena.
Lo meto en la derecha.
La izquierda tengo a Cristiano.
Ha jugado derecha y media punta.
Media punta. Netvech no. Banda derecha no.
Mis cojones 33.
Vale, vale.
Tranquil.
Es que Franza en Transfer Market que jugó un partido de dole pivote
en Copa contra la Astorga.
Vale, vale, vale.
Ya está, balón de oro. Tranquila.
Tengo más opciones.
Tranquila.
Adri, tienes aquí el Iny
que creo que es un poco porro.
Leo Messi y Ribery.
Kevin de Bruin.
Vale. Media punta, evidentemente.
Ya tienes la línea de tres cuartos.
¿Cómo?
¿Dónde? ¿Dónde?
¿Dónde?
Igual el media punta más
canónico de los últimos
5 o 10 años.
Hay que abre.
A ver, si me lo coloques de media punta igual no lo cojo.
Claro, es que...
Eso es lo que me lo ha dicho yo.
En media punta, perro.
Vale, pues a ver, un segundo.
Uf, qué buena esta.
Ah, no puedo.
Me hace mucha gracia.
Alex, encontrado yo que sé a un portugués
y viendo que tiene esta...
Sí, sí, sí, sí, sí.
Era en portugués además.
Es que tengo aquí una duda
con dos.
No sé con cuál quedarme.
Ah, no, claro.
Venga.
Bueno, pues aquí no me lo... Lo quito,
¿vale?
Te voy a dejar ahí.
O sea, lo quitas.
Sí, lo quito.
Porque pensaba que me lo ibas a comprar
como doble piagote.
Ahora esto me ha dejado loco
un poco.
Venga, pues Sergio
Ramos.
Molt bona.
Sergio Ramos.
Pero si tú tenías ya Real Madrid, Miguel.
No.
Sí.
Ah, claro.
Claro, claro, claro.
Es verdad que lleva
ocho años jugando en el Real Madrid,
pero cedido en el Paris Saint-Germain, ¿sabes?
Entonces, cuenta los partidos del PSG.
Parecido, parecido.
Y me queda Sergio Ramos
y Van der Sar.
Edwin.
Vale.
Alex.
Es a Xavi,
a Nethved, Cristiano y Titianry.
Vale.
Mi acompañante del Centro del Campo
para Xavi Hernández es
Steven Gerrard.
Muy bien.
¿A quién ha cogido Adri antes?
A Ramos
y Van der Sar.
Vale.
Y me toca a mí, ¿verdad?
Sí.
Bueno, pues ya va siendo hora
de quemar la
bala uruguay. Diego Godin.
Atlético de Madrid. Muy buena.
Sí.
Muy buena. De hecho, era una de mis
siguientes elecciones.
Pues ya no.
Goody, goody.
Vale.
Habéis elegido todos a Madridistas, ¿no?
Sí. Diego Godin.
Ah, sí, claro. Yo tengo a Madridista.
Vale.
Pues yo voy a coger, me sorprende,
el porro de Chiellini
teniendo a Paolo Maldini.
Lateral izquierdo,
que es como juega en el siglo XXI.
Espérate, espérate.
Pero ya es italiano.
Ah, bueno, porque vas a coger todo el Milan.
Espérate.
Paolo Maldini, como he dicho.
Y
vamos a coger
a
Philipp Lahm.
Oh, qué buenos, Philipp Lahm, tío.
Qué buenos, Philipp Lahm,
tío. Gracias. Gracias.
Le podría poner de pivote,
pero no. Bueno, bueno.
Vale.
Vas tú, Adri, ¿no?
No, se acabó de coger
hace nada. Fanahuel. No, bollón.
Fanahuel. Ah, vale.
Es que Álex tiene que luchar
contra sus ideas,
contra las posiciones y contra
el orden establecido del sorteo. El orden que nunca
sé cuál es. No sé qué decir. Álex, tu turno.
Pues me toca. Además diría que la mayoría de
veces es igual porque casi siempre gana Adri
el sorteo. Sí, eso es verdad.
Algo hay, una mano negra ahí.
Oye, ¿por qué? Porque cuando hay
un poco de estafa es mano negra.
Mano negra y cuando
tal. Eso se
cuenta muy bien en negros, no hay negros
en el tíbet. Muy buen podcast, ¿eh?
Y ¿por qué es malo ser
siniestro y a educar se llama
adiestrar? Oh, muy buena esa.
Muy buen round.
No es mío. Esto es de Haloner
Liga Bazooka. Los que no vean la Liga Bazooka
no sé en qué estéis pensando.
Ehm.
En el GTA 6 va a haber mucho Bazooka.
Guau, qué ganas tengo.
¿Qué has cogido, Quintana, en la última?
Los dos laterales, Maldini y Lam.
Vale.
Maldini y Lam.
Dos.
Ehm.
Rodrigo Hernández.
Cascante.
Balón de oro.
Tiene mucho balón de oro, ¿no?
Eh, eh, más partidos ya en el City, ¿no?
Entiendo que sí.
Sí, sí, seguro. Digo yo que sí, pero
bueno, sí, porque es imposible
lo contrario. Nada, he dicho una tontería.
Sí, sí, sí. Bueno.
De hecho, triplica el segundo suceso.
Sí, sí, sí. Lo he pensado y he dicho una tontería.
Ehm.
¿Me toca, no? No.
Me toca a mí. Ah, vale.
Por favor, es siempre el mismo
No liéis. Bueno.
No liéis. Ales tiene a...
Es que cuela, es que cuela. A Xavi Gerrard
en el doble pivote, a Nedved
y a Cristiano Ronaldo, media punta y banda izquierda
y a Titán Ría arriba.
Este creo que es muy bueno
que es...
Demanjavi Dic. Ah.
Man United.
Un poco...
No, pues a mí me gusta, eh.
Yo tenía aquí... De lo mejores defensas
del siglo XXI, macho.
Adrián Blanco.
Chau. Ehm...
Tudududu. A ver,
porque ya tengo, claro, muchas nacionalidades.
Ehm...
Alexander Arnold.
Vale. Y Inglaterra de Liverpool.
Y...
Felipe Luis.
Oh, qué buena.
Molt bona. Muy buena.
Ehm...
Ya tienes la defensa completada, ¿verdad?
Van der Sar, Trent, Chiellini, Ramos, Felipe Luis.
Tienes a Messi, Kevin de Bruyne y
Ribery. Te faltan doble pivote y delantero.
No, Kevin de Bruyne no. Ah, al final que no has cogido.
Perdona. Claro.
¿Qué te pasa?
Es que he completado
ya el equipo porque me he tirado...
Ahora me he completado, me he tirado ahora un
triple.
Brutal.
Está loquísimo, tío.
Sí, sí. La verdad es que he visto de un movimiento
que no... ¿Qué tengo que hacer?
No voy a preguntar porque no lo entiendo.
A quién le toca. A ti.
Ah, me toca a mí.
Bueno, me he quedado...
Yo lo digo, estaba esperando.
Estaba esperando.
Me voy a quedar con...
Es que...
Me duele quemar esta bala.
Bueno, no, es verdad.
Ya me acuerdo.
¿Hais elegido todos aquí?
Eh...
No, yo creo que Adri...
Adri me podría fastidiar. Voy a elegir a
Ricardo y Sexson dos Santos.
Cacá con el Milan.
No, yo ya no puedo, tengo a Felipe.
Ah, sí, claro, tienes a Felipe.
Me lo podría haber ahorrado, la verdad. Porque los demás tenés media punta.
Cacá con
el Milan, evidentemente.
Vale.
Y me toca a mí
las opciones.
Madrid ya habéis elegido
todos.
Sí.
Vale.
Vale, vale, vale, vale, vale, vale, vale.
Creo que es el primer draft
que no he metido una
sin grabenada, ¿no?
Bueno, todavía queda, ¿eh?
Los lanzadores lo deseados, ¿eh?
Claro, yo tengo aquí...
Yo tengo mi plan, si me salgo del plan, ya puedo entrar en
Barrena, ¿no?
Ahora es cuando viene lo verdaderamente
fino.
Sí, sí, totalmente.
Ay, tengo... Ah, no, claro.
Es que es
complicado de narices.
Totalmente.
Vale, a ver.
Me ha dolido la de Rodri, ¿eh?
La de Rodri es muy buena.
Sí, la verdad que no la había pensado, pero
es muy bueno, sí.
Vale.
Voy a coger
la de Rodri.
Ah.
Fua, es complicadísimo.
La combinación que tengo aquí.
Guapo.
Voy a coger
a
Río Ferdinand.
Muy buena Río Ferdinand.
United.
Vídech, ¿no? Y Río Ferdinand, sí.
Hombre.
Esto Matiz, ¿no?
No, Vídech.
Ah, ostras. Yo digo, vaya porro.
Claro, y tú lo dices, no.
No, no, sabes que es lo peor?
Que lo tengo bien apuntado.
Mi cabeza era Matiz, tío.
Digo, digo, digo, hasta luego.
Hasta luego.
Vale.
Y tenía aquí
la duda porque
quería, tengo al del
Real Madrid libre, ¿vale?
Para coger.
¿Qué sucede? Que tengo aquí la duda
y tenía apuntado a Courtois.
Pero, por
exigencias de otras posiciones,
voy a coger
el portero con más zamoras de la historia,
Jan Oblak.
Ka...
Mira que me estoy apuntando uno
para sustituir a Oblak.
Porque me la acabas, me acabas,
me acabas de hacer... Reventar.
De hacer la reventación.
Vale.
¿A quién le toca a mí?
Creo que a mí, ¿no? Joder, Alex.
Te voy a matar. Te voy a matar.
Tú vas detrás de un abuelo de Adri.
Jamás mío. Jamás. Nunca.
Nunca. Never.
O sea, a quitarle faltan los dos pibotes,
un central y un lateral derecho, ¿no?
No, lateral derecho tengo a Alam.
Correcto. Venga.
Ya me parecía raro.
Yo la bala del portero, es que la bala del portero
la tengo bien asegurada. Permíteme recordar
lo que llevas a Raph, Van Dijk,
Diego Godin, Modric, Rodri,
Kaká, Harry Kane.
Correcto.
Me voy a quedar para el lateral izquierdo
a Alfonso Davis.
¡No! ¡No!
Lo reventaste.
O sea, dos seguidas que tengo ahí aquí.
Y encima te toca ahora.
Ah, me toca a mí, ¿no? Vale.
Bueno, pues nada.
Vistos los acontecimientos.
¿Qué te parece?
Me gusta mucho.
Vamos a ver.
Voy a decir
mi otro central.
Es...
Espérate, todos tenéis extremo derecho.
¿A ti qué te importa?
Yo no tengo. Apúntatelo.
No, no tiene Nahuel.
Nahuel, ¿tú que...
¿Tienes Paris Saint-Germain?
Sí, tengo a Raph.
Vale, pues voy a coger central
Nesta, Milan.
Muy buena.
Pro 6, papá.
Adri.
Me toca a mí, ¿no?
Adri, dos.
Voy a coger
a uno de mis delanteros.
Miroslav Klose.
¿Klose con qué equipo?
Hola, Lazio.
¡Qué buena!
Un poco porro el nombre.
Un poco porro el nombre, pero...
¡Oye!
¿Cuánto goles ha metido en los mundiales?
Máximo la hora de este era mundiales.
Aquí hay tendencia a infravalorar
los mundiales.
Me sorprende mucho. Ya no lo podéis
escoger ninguno.
Pero ya no lo podéis escoger ninguno.
Pero me sorprende muchísimo
que no hayamos cogido ninguno
a Totti.
Roma.
Era mí.
Yo lo tenía puesto,
pero como
Nesbett tenía que ser media punta,
y luego tenía Nesta,
italiano.
Se me complicaba.
Vale, y el otro.
Portugués y del Chelsea
de codificador de co.
Muy buena.
Lo de la del club.
Tú hiciste la tarea.
Estaba aquí mirando.
La tenía ya puntadito.
Hiciste la tarea.
Esto es complicadísimo, tío.
Lo que me queda a telita.
Yo me he apagado.
Me toca a mí.
Le toca a Álex.
No, no.
Sabes lo que creía, pero uno
llega a dudar de todo.
Vale.
Mi portero...
¿Qué porteros tenéis?
¿Me podéis actualizar?
Van der Sar y Jan O'Black.
Tivo Courtois se queda sin ser elegido.
Vale.
Para mí Manuel Neuer.
Aleman Bayern.
Vale.
Lo podés haber escogido después
porque ya tiene Alfonso Divis.
Me cago en la masa.
Neuer es muy buena opción.
Sí, sí.
Por teros, a mí me parece fácil
elegir.
Bueno,
yo no tengo
portero, pero...
A ver, es que
tengo despejados los dos extremos
que ya no podés coger ninguno
si no estoy yo muy equivocado.
De Jan O'Black le pilla el extremo
derecho, pero no creo
que me fastidie.
De hecho, me puede
fastidiar De Jan O'.
De Jan O'Black,
el que se va a cerrará
en Hazard, Chelsea.
Era mi segunda opción
si me fallaba la primera.
Vale.
Un momentín, que estoy comprobando
una cosa.
No hay problemas hoy.
Cuidado.
Cuidado también.
Vale.
Pues vamos a coger
a...
Roberto Fabiana Ayala,
Argentina,
Valencia.
Y...
Puta de esto.
Aquí tengo dudas.
¿Puedo haceros
una pregunta?
Brasileños tenéis todos?
Sí.
Vale.
¿Y argentinos?
Sí.
Y argentino no tengo.
Vale. Pero tú tenías PSG.
Sí.
Yo también he mirado a Di María.
Vale.
No, sí, este no puedo.
Este no puedo.
Tengo una buena.
Pues...
Qué putada.
Vale.
¿Qué haces?
¿Dónde has jugado más partidos?
Vale.
¿Os puedo hacer una pregunta?
Depende.
¿Desde cuándo podemos permiso
para hacer preguntas?
Yo lo pido porque nunca sé si se puede.
Levanta la mano.
¿Os la puedo hacer o no?
Sí.
¿A quién pondréis?
Yaya Ture.
Hombre, yo Yaya Ture
de aquí a Lima.
Yaya Ture.
Pues...
Yaya Ture con el City.
Costa marfileño.
Te toca.
Nahuel Miranda de armas.
Te falta un porcero,
un extremo...
Y el extremo izquierdo. No tengo claro del extremo.
Creo que nadie me puede joder.
Todo el mundo tiene extremo izquierdo, ¿no?
Sí.
Voy a dar una vuelta a lo del extremo.
El portero es Gianluigi Buffon.
Espera, Nahuel.
¿Asar de media? No.
Asar de la derecha.
Tengo Asar de la derecha.
No.
Asar de la derecha, mis cojones.
Como que en la derecha.
Como que en la derecha, tío.
Bueno, cuando prefieres.
¿Asar en la izquierda?
Me hacéis un favor.
Vale, vale.
Entonces, ¿has dicho?
Gianluigi Buffon.
Vale.
Y le toca a Alex.
Mi lateral derecho es
Maicon del Inter.
Maicon.
No tienes a ningún brasileño, ¿verdad?
No. Vale.
Adrian Blanco. Tienes a Van der Sar.
Trent Chiellini. Ramos.
Felipe Luis. Deco.
Leo Messi. Ribery.
Miroslav Klose.
Con los delanteros que hay.
Porro Klose.
¿Cómo?
Un poco porro Klose, ¿no?
Un poquito porrer, sí.
Un poquito.
Adri.
No has cogido a Ronaldo Nazario.
Has cogido a Klose.
No, pero podrías haber cogido
teniendo lo que tienes
a un agüero.
Sí, tengo a Messi.
Que comparten nacionalidad con ellos.
Creo, ¿eh?
Es posible.
Rakitic, ¿dónde lo ibas a poner?
¿En la media punta o en el centro de campo?
Creo que lo puedes poner a las dos posiciones.
Vaya ratoncín, ¿eh?
No sé, no sé.
No sé, Rick.
A Rakitic le puedes poner las dos posiciones.
Claro.
I'm not sure, Rick.
Además, tú tienes las dos posiciones abiertas, Adri.
Ya, ya, ya.
Es que el otro pibote, claro, con las
nacionalidades que ya tengo...
De hecho, tú acabas ya, ¿no? Porque tienes dos selecciones.
Sí, sí, sí.
Bueno, pues mi lateral
izquierdo va a ser tremendo porro.
¿Y no es Pedro?
No.
Claro, delantero, otro delantero.
Es que de Falcao me ha reventado, macho.
Falcao...
¿Te puedo ayudar con una que no puedo...?
A ver.
Los tengo ya, si no, creo.
Tienes abierto Milan, ¿no?
Hombre, hay un balón de oro ucraniano que...
Se va.
Se va Rakitic, sí.
O...
o...
Sidorf Rakitic.
No, Sidorf no puedo porque tengo a Bandersaar.
Ah, coño.
Claro, es que ahí está el problema
con el pibote.
Cuando hemos la antes del Milan...
Sepchenko Rakitic.
Muy bien.
Sí, venga, vale. Sí, sí.
Estaba pensando en hacer encaja de Euruin, pero claro, no voy a poder.
Al final. Venga, vale, pues lo cierro así.
Sepchenko Rakitic.
De hecho, has escogido mejor del anterior en la segunda que en la primera.
Porque ha habido ahí un pase de la muerte.
Oye, que hater eres de close, ¿no?
A ver...
Es que estamos pesados, close, oíete.
Tu viste una novia polaca, ¿eh?
En estos niveles...
Madre, vea.
Me acabo de marcar una singa de nada.
Vale, el once de Adrián Blanco que ya he acabado es Bandersaar.
Revisemos todos para que no haya liada como la que le yo en el descenso.
Bandersaar, Trent, Chiellini, Ramos, Felipe Luis.
Sí.
Leo Messi, Deco, Rakitic, Ribery.
Sepchenko, close.
Hay que tener en cuenta que Deco va con Gorto y close con Lachio.
Eso es.
Ese Deco doble pivote en un 4-4-2.
Deco, Rakitic, ahí no defiende ni tu prima, ¿eh?
Bueno, van por estas Ramos y Chiellini, chico.
¿Qué quieres?
Presiona arriba, Adri, ¿eh?
Como se rompan las primeras líneas de fútbol.
No, no, no.
Adri, ¿eh? Como se rompan las primeras líneas de fútbol está jodido.
Alex.
Te queda un lateral izquierdo y...
Y ya está, ¿no?
En el lateral izquierdo, sí, en este modelo derecho.
Vale.
Que lo dejo para el final porque ya no lo puedo decir nadie.
Sí.
Mi lateral izquierdo, mi sin grabenada...
Verás, verás.
Me he quedado en blanco contra Don Barrera.
Verás.
Hazlo.
Josco Guardiol.
Muerde mía.
Te digo uno por si quieres cambiar...
Ah, no, claro, porque vas a escoger a Di María, ¿no?
Claro, voy a escoger a Di María extremo derecho.
Entonces me quita a todos los argentinos.
Al Pupi Zanetti.
No puedo ponerle un no mechnes porque ya tengo portugués.
Mi opción ahí era Alfonso Davis.
Que, bueno, luego me ha venido bien porque he puesto a Neuer de portero.
Y es que, chavales, o sea, estaba mirando aquí,
ves left back since 21st century y no sale nada.
Te meto a Di María.
Es cool, pero tengo a...
Sí, ya, ciérramelo.
Me meto a Di María y al otro y ya está.
¿Qué madre está? ¿Tienes el 11, Álex?
Lo leo, lo leo.
Manuel Noyer, Maicon,
Vidic, Nesta, Josco Guardiol,
Xavi, Gerrard,
Ángel Di María, Nesbeth,
Cristiano Ronaldo, Henry.
En el Xavi y Gerrard tampoco defienden ni Dios, ¿eh?
Sí, pero tenemos la pelota.
Ah, vale, vale.
Uno la tiene y otro llega.
Cuando la tengas, pues no te amenazas.
Vale, Nau, te quedan a ti...
Eh, nada, me queda el extremo derecho.
Sí.
No sé cómo hemos hecho, creo que nos hemos saltado antes a Álex.
O sea, que me habéis hecho...
O sea, por eso cuando pregunto...
Sí, sí.
Eh, dame un segundo.
Yo creo que no va a haber problema con esto.
Pero quiero comprobar...
Quiero hacer una rápida comprobación.
Yo no te lo puedo quitar, ¿eh? Lo puedes decir.
No, no, no. O sea...
¿A quién te refieres?
No lo sé, no sé qué. O sea, yo voy a coger...
Ahora te lo digo, es del Madrid.
Es que ha decidido no...
Eh, vale, perfecto, perfecto.
Con cuatro partidos vas
en el Fútbol Club Barcelona,
que en el Real Madrid me quedo para la banda derecha
a Luis Figo.
Oh, muy bueno.
No tenías del Barça.
No tenía del Barça.
Oh, muy bueno.
Hola. Bien tirado.
Pues menos mal que te hemos puesto Azar en banda izquierda, ¿eh, perro?
Perro, perro.
No, no, me ha venido mucho mejor. De hecho estaba petando con la izquierda.
Estaba petando.
Tu equipo es Gigi Buffon, Arraja Kimi,
Bandai Diego Dina Alfonso Davis,
Luca Modric Rodri,
Luis Figo, Kaká Azar, Harry Kane.
Ostras, muy bueno el equipo de Nau, eh.
Y yo
completo
con el jugador del Real Madrid,
Xavi Alonso,
en el centro del campo, junto a Yaya
Turé, para hacer un centro del campo compensado,
como el de mis compañeros, completo con...
¿Tienes a un programa de Gimodric?
No, no, no. Tú y yo hemos sido
canónicos. ¿Double balón de oro?
¿Cuántos balones de oro tiene Xavi Alonso?
¿Cuánto tiene Yaya Turé?
Jano Black en portería,
Lam Ayala, Río Ferdinand, Paolo Maldini,
Mohamed Salah, Xavi Alonso
de la turé Neymar Jr., Radamiel Falcao,
Kylian Mbappé. Ese es mi equipo.
Muy bueno también, ¿no? Muy bueno también el de Miguel.
No hay ningún error, ¿no?
Sabéis el que nos hemos dejado todos.
Juan Mimue. Me había puesto
Roberto Totototo, eh.
Robert Lewandowski.
Ah, claro, sí. Lewandowski, nos hemos dejado a Zidane.
Van Nistelrooy.
Van Nistelrooy, nos hemos dejado
a Agüero, a Iniesta.
Adriano. Adriano.
Adriano, yo lo tenía pensado.
Pepe. Jamejainmil.
Bale. A Kroos le había dado una vuelta.
Claro, era O'Crosso Modric. Nos hemos dejado
a uno que me sorprende.
A ver, hemos cogido muy buenos extremos de derecho, ¿eh?
Al final son...
¿Qué onda? Ay.
Se acabó el juego. El cable.
El cable.
No es el cable, es que hay veces que, bueno.
No sé.
Hemos cogido a Salah, Messi y Ángel Di María,
pero nos hemos dejado a Robben.
Sí, pero es que...
Yo tenía Van Dyck desde el principio.
Lo he pensado.
Yo lo tenía, pero quería poner a
Alfonso Divis de la TV izquierda
con eso y ha dicho, bueno, pues como
Di María me vale para este moderecho,
me toano y el rectorcero.
Pero si no has puesto a Alfonso Divis de la TV izquierda.
No, porque lo ha quitado.
Me lo ha quitado.
Yo lo tenía puesto aquí apuntado. Que te haya jodido el equipo.
Alfonso Divis también...
Bueno, o sea, yo creo que
la comparación de Alfonso Divis y Joscowardial...
Yo no he utilizado el como en el argentino.
Que eso también me ha dolido.
Estaba Andrews Robertson
en la tabla izquierda, ¿vale?
Sí, pero es que tenía que ser...
Ah.
Pues haber puesto a Lampard.
Sí, Lampard tampoco hemos cogido, ni Terry.
No, la tendría que haber hecho
porque luego del Chelsea no...
No, Asliq.
No, había una que era buenísima.
Judd Bellingham, yo creo que debe ser Borussia Dortmund, ¿no?
Dortmund, claro.
Judd Bellingham.
He pensado en Royce, pero soy un poco hater de Marco Royce.
Ya había pensado en Hummels también.
Pero tenía a Lampard.
Así que no hemos cogido ninguna.
Joder, Lampard me mola mucho, tío.
Uno de mis jugadores fetiche.
Yo estoy muy contento con mi defensa. Lampard y a la Ferdinand Maldini.
Bueno, chicos.
No, al final, ni tan mal.
Oye, buenos 11.
Que sean los Pizzarritas, por un lado,
los que decidan quién ha ganado,
y por otro, los que,
quitando a todos estos futbolistas,
hagan su 11.
A ver qué tal.
No es fácil, ¿eh?
Buen reto.
Venga, Pizzarritas, os la vemos en la cajita de comentarios
como siempre. Muchísimas gracias.